Michael I wonder if you could tell us
what it was like for you when Alejandra
and you read sent you the script and
said that there might be a few
biographical coincidences in the
character you might be reading for and
but you know it was obvious so we I
guess maybe I went whoa okay and maybe
we spent a little time with that but
honestly you know he he's an interesting
such an interesting person and he's
passionate and he was a little tone down
the first time and he was more curious
like how do you work and there was a
tiny language cultural you know
adjustment not much as English is really
good but we felt each other out and then
we relaxed and had fun and he's you know
then we went outside and he was you know
feeling more comfortable being his great
alejandro self and I don't know was
there any really reason to discuss this
for me I didn't feel like doing the
extra work I wanted to do the basic work
because I'm lazy and I just wanted to
get down to whatever was because I knew
it would be hard so let's just get to
that you know Edward you have a lot of
experience in the New York theatre world
when you read this script you feel it
nailed it and it was true to the
experience if you've spent any part of
your life especially your your young
life an early career in the New York
theater then there are those films that
sort of just sit within the tribe as
these kind of classics um you know the
dresser or with Nell and I or you know
21st 20th century the great John
Barrymore movie or just you know movies
about theater people and their absurdity
and and I'm and those those you know
those hold sort of a special place in
the heart of a lot of us and and I felt
as I was even reading through it page
after page just just made me more and
more convinced it it could be one of
those sorts of things because they they
were they were just I don't understand
actually how like to Argentines and a
Mexican crawled
so far inside the details I was actually
a GOG at it like I was like
and turns out one of the four of them is
a New York playwright but even even he
it was very interesting talking to them
like I I've never really sorted out how
they how they you know hit it so
astutely but i laughed a lot and i
thought it was terrific and i thought
that um I thought that it was um this
incredible balance of ascends up ascends
up and sort of a loving satirical stick
a fork and a lot of people on almost
every side of the equation but it was
all but it was also at the same time
like doing sort of that impossible thing
that that to me Fellini does that where
it was also just very profound there was
a lot of things in it that really that
really speak to not just any artist but
really anybody walking down the street
with that self-critical voice in their
head saying you you are in trouble
you've really strayed I mean it was kind
of a dream scenario where you it was a
character I've never even gotten close
to diving into before and that was a
huge amazing opportunity and with a
director like that and a script like
that and a cast like this it was some
yeah it's kind of a dream scenario was
it clear to the three of you when you
got the script that mohandro was going
to pursue this rather extraordinary
almost one-shot technique throughout the
whole very quick I mean it was pretty
fundamental to it it wasn't like we it
wasn't like we rehearsed and you know a
week before he went oh by the way you
know it was it was um part of the deal
yeah it was part of the deal
well let's talk about that rehearsal
process I know it was three weeks long
was the camera person there throughout
kind of as an active John lusha the
producer said and I actually didn't even
get this he said we've kind of made the
movie three times and I saw that two
times but I what happened was they
because we only had a brief window to
have access to the theater at the st.
James theatre we couldn't rehearse there
and it's you can't make the movie that
rehearsal and then you and it's not it
can't just be talking about the
characters and maybe getting it up on
or maybe not just it's not that kind of
thing it has to be worth product
specific to the actual physical space
that you're going to do it yeah yeah and
you then you so they measured everything
and they were working on it while they
could with camera moves and everything
back here well I wasn't I was still in
LA not working on another movie or
something then they we they were in a
soundstage and you tape it off down to
okay the steps are here here's where you
were going down steps turn and it wasn't
indulgent at all it was the only way you
could do it and I thought holy moley
this is this is unbelievable
and but you can't think too much about
it being unbelievable because then
that's too much you just have to embrace
it and and roll with it but that that in
and of itself knocked me out that you
know they would we were and when you by
the time we got there and they then they
built the set they reconstructed the
sick it was eerie
that you got there and you went oh yeah
right
it sort of looked like and I had never
seen it and I went oh yeah this is yeah
right this is what I thought it would be
based on what I have no idea and then
when you see the actual place and it's
duplication mind-blowing was it kind of
like a theatrical production in the
sense that you were choreographed on
every single law I mean yes and no the
same thing is usually true of a film and
I don't think that the essence of
theatrical experience is one that
there's an audience there which there
wasn't for us and to that you you
actually go out take the baton and you
carry it through it's sort of as an act
you do the whole thing for better for
worse and that's it and and and this
this was like making a very very
different sort of film it was but it was
it was still very much
the kind of collaboration that you go
through on a film with a camera crew and
everybody else it was just it was just
much much much more honestly was more
intimate it because a lot of times you
know it's it's sort of a habit and
understandable habit on film sets that
usually a shot is being set up and
virtually
everyone involved goes do I work this no
I don't work this you know what I mean
and a certain percentage of people just
sort of take a powder but with this
everybody was on all the time you know
anybody involved is on all the time and
and it created it created like a really
wonderful kind of mutual reliance mutual
dependency and then this kind of great
celebratory feeling that you don't
usually get on a set because it was very
hard to get Alejandro happy with these
enormous pieces and when he got when he
got there you know when you're winding
toward the end of the day and you might
not even have that huge chunk that he
needs and and you you and everybody gets
through it and you kind of get there and
he screams like a World Cup announcer
and you know it's just a very very it
really was on it was a very emotionally
and art and creatively exuberant
experience much more than most films
I've worked in there's a very pointed
moment where the camera was very close
to my face and to Michael's when we have
that conversation in the room or we kind
of give each other a piece of our minds
and I think there was something there
possibly but I was so close to Michael's
face to in that moment that it felt you
know just like a like a souped-up
version of what it would feel like to
finally unload on your father so it you
know was like an I guess another person
in the scene but a ghost that just sort
of we knew how to we had rehearsed so
much and it was so choreographed that
once that was happening fluidly there
was this sort of feeling that you could
let go and you weren't gonna have to
stop and set up coverage you know which
you do on on every other film you you
have to stop and start over and find the
energy again and you never had to do
that so it sort of was like this you
know magical invisible animal that's
sort of you know I think if I could add
to that I think that shot is a great to
me it's one of the it's one of the ones
I just sort of shake my head in
amazement at in the in the film if you
want to look at like what's what's the
particular poem on to call it that
that's produced by people working in
this mode you know Alejandro and and
Chivo the cinematographer like you you
you can't imagine a movie in which a
person dresses down someone out else
like that where they're not cutting to
the reaction of the person and it not
only the instinct to not only just
decide you know what I'm not going to
attempt to drift back to the corner I'm
not gonna attempt to find a way to get
into and over I'm not gonna do anything
I'm gonna go right in on it go all the
way through it but not only go all the
way through it stay with it in the
silence at the end and understand what's
happening on his face by the collapse of
regret that happens on her face that's
the kind of stuff that I was just like
yeah you know didn't knock my socks off
you know you gotta understand like I
when I was growing up my friends and I
used to take the HBO program guide and
we would go through it and look for
night shift in the rotation and fold the
corners down the Levin a.m. you know to
it ii am like and we would watch that
movie like over and over and over again
and do like lines like you know she's
reducing like you know like we we we
would like we would do these things so
for me there was an element that when
you get into the types of things that
are that lead up to that fight that uh
you know him faking me out i had a very
very difficult time like holding it
together i it was hard for me to not you
know laughs laughs he really makes me
laugh and i i i I haven't looked at it
but there's a lot of those takes you can
see that me doing sort of a Jerry
Seinfeld like I'm kind of like like like
really fighting to keep the corners of
my mouth down my character basically
like I my view of him was sort of like I
had I had on my script just like the
Dorothy Parker line scratch and actor
you'll find an actress and I just
thought that's the key to him here's
basically I do this is a big deal this
is gonna be hard it's really good
boy I sure hope I'm up to it so why
don't I meet Michael just do what you
always do go to work on it and then
throw everything else into the faith bag
to the sure hope Imam right I sure hope
my instincts are right and and try to
paste it at correctly because I knew I
wouldn't have the luxury of go well
missed that one but I got you know I got
a bunch more in me and he's gonna go
he's got to come around and cover me
here there's none of that that's all
gone so having the alter ego really was
I got it was obvious what that was that
was frankly not that you know you know
what that is you know if you know
anything about anything
and we all accept we've got that and
just not be afraid to be as brutally
harsh and I think I'll also often
truthful as he is and commit to it and
then sometimes I guess maybe at the
beginning when the you know
Alejandro would explain it maybe it
would seem a bit but now that I'm
talking about him remembering some
things thinking ooh
you know that's I think that he's over
selling the idea that maybe this I needs
to be a little more underhanded you know
the Birdman the the negative ego kind of
has to be a little underhanded it may be
but that's not him you know he you know
you're you know Latin art is crazy man
seriously blood off of hearts and
crosses or you know it's like intense
art if you come from you know you look
at that
Salvador Dali you know any of those guys
I go c'mon so what I got here you know I
got a handful of that this guy so I said
alright that's what he that's what he
wants to do man you know no really I
thought you know that's what this dude
is he's he's all that and I go just give
in to what he wants and just I'm the
vessel he's this dude's vision you know
just roll with it cuz now had I not had
he not been the director of Babel and
had he not been the director of all
these other things I might have gone
hold on a minute we got to talk
but you
go I'm on this ship I'm okay I feel
pretty good about this